a little while ago when I was traveling
I don't remember what city or state I
was in but I attended a local church
before my my flight and it's always kind
of a game of Russian roulette to go to a
church out of town when you're traveling
and I guess I lost the game this time
around I walked into this church and I I
knew immediately what I was in for
because I noticed that the choir members
have you can call it a choir they were
they were all dressed in shorts and
flip-flops and everybody was talking not
just the choir but everybody everybody
was talking they were treating this time
before church as kind of a cocktail hour
and so people were gabbing and gossiping
and carrying on
nobody was praying you look around there
was no prayer anywhere it to be found in
the church and that's how it is a lot of
modern churches there's always noise
always there always has to be noise and
sounds and never silence even for a
moment
at some point in recent history we
decided that a church is a place that
should always be filled with noise and
there must never be silence in a church
when of course a church is exactly the
place where you should be able to go and
get some silence but there needs to be
silence in church because silence
facilitates mental prayer which is
something that should be happening in a
church it's part of the whole reason a
church exists anyway finally church
started and the choir or the the jam
band for Jesus whatever it was they
played a song that sounded like a like a
cross between kind of a 90s Disney
soundtrack and maybe an easy listening
favorite that you would find if you
scrolled through your aunt's second
generation iPod
it wasn't contemporary it wasn't
relevant it wasn't good
but it also wasn't traditional and that
was the whole point
because tradition is yucky that's old we
can't have tradition
anything that existed prior to 1967 we
can't have any of that that's all bad
because it's old old things are bad the
singer was the lead singer of this band
was relatively talented but he carried
on like he carry on like a lead singer
of a band and he you got this distinct
impression that he was fishing for
applause not that he was worshiping the
Lord of the universe
he wasn't now music and church should be
bringing us all into this you know
reverent state of awe before the the
sacredness the holiness of God right
should be bringing should be this
communal experience which elevates us
and brings us up towards God that's what
music that's what church music is
supposed to do it's not supposed to
bring us back down to earth it's not
supposed to remind us of the culture no
it's not supposed to do that it's not
supposed to make a stand in all of this
very talented band
it's not even you know it's not even
about bringing us it's it's it's it's
not even about like bonding us with each
other like a campfire song or something
it's a it's all about togetherness and
being together it's not actually what
church music is supposed to do it's
about it's about bringing us all towards
God and it certainly did not succeed in
doing that at all
and it seems like it's wasn't designed
to and a lot of church music these days
is really not designed for that it's not
trying to do that so the pastor when it
was you know time for him to deliver his
sermon he opened up with a round of
jokes which were not funny but at least
they succeeded in being unserious which
I guess is close enough and the sermon
was jam-packed with youth slang and pop
culture and he mentioned some TV shows
and Netflix he made sports metaphors he
didn't do anything with the metaphors he
just kind of hung them out there so that
we could be impressed that he knows
about these things and the reason why
knife this all seen I'm depicting I've
seen things like this a million times
the reason why this one still sticks in
my head even a couple of years later is
because I distinctly remember he made
this reference to Angry Birds okay this
is a couple years ago but even by then
this was a very dated reference
but and so I just cringing out of like
oh my gosh but it did the job I guess of
letting us know that the guy speaking
also uses smartphones and or at least he
used a smartphone at some point in the
last five years and I guess the young
people in attendance were supposed to go
oMG he totally gets us lol guys did you
hear him talk about Angry Birds
unfortunately what was left out of his
sermon
was any semblance of an insight or a
challenge or a truth or a call to action
or a point
and about halfway in I I turn to look
around at my fellow congregants and you
know what I saw
a lot of empty seats
a disinterested yawn echoed through the
halls
and the people who were sitting in the
pews what few of them there were they
look to be on average about 87 years old
and this was clearly everything I was
witnessing from the pop-culture
references the sermon the casual dress
the music okay all of the the e
reverence okay
all of this was designed clearly to
appeal to young people but I looked
around and it was it looked like a
nursing home I didn't I was I was
probably a youngest person there by
about 50 years I'll tell you another
quick story a different Church this one
closer to me
before beforehand they a giant projector
screen dropped from the ceiling
and they played a rap video okay a
Christian rap video
that head had been I guess produced by
the church youth group
and it was
painful
painful but I looked around in all the
old folks in the church and it was
mostly old folks they were all smiling
but they thought it was really cute you
could tell they were really cute they
could see their grandchildren and they
thought it was the cutest thing
uh as for the younger people we were all
cringing so hard that our faces hurt you
could tell we were all worried that our
face would get stuck like this because
that's how hard we were created so one
of those cringe moments where you can't
even look up you're just you just want
to shrink into it you're you're
experiencing secondhand embarrassment to
a degree that is just it's it's causing
physical anxiety and you
one more story this one not for me
someone wrote to me a few weeks ago to
tell me about the local
nondenominational church that they just
left because the pastor had embarked on
this mission to win back young people
and this mission apparently involved
introducing an electric guitar
because you know those young people
knows electric-guitar encouraging people
to dress more casually at church and
giving sermons on tolerance and racism
and injecting again pop-culture
references into them as much as possible
you get the point the point is that
Christian leaders in America church
leaders have set out to win back young
people to win back the young generation
and they certainly need to do that
because the young generation is less
religious more atheistic more secular
than any generation before in American
history but in many cases in most cases
probably they've set out to win back
these lost sheep by trying to be cool
and relevant and irreverent but all this
ever succeeds in doing is impressing the
aging people in the pews who ruined
everything by injecting this garbage
into the church in the first place
they're the ones who first decided that
the experience at church should resemble
your experience at a coffee shop or at a
really bad Rock on for a concert okay
this is like my parents generation
they're the ones who came up with all
this and so even now to this day they're
the only ones impressed by it the young
people are not
they love it their kids do not love it
as is clearly evident by the fact that
their kids are not going to church
and most of them have left the faith
completely now you can kind of
understand right because think of what a
secular young person imagine what he
would think if he was looking to give
Christianity a try and the first service
he ever attended was of the type I just
described
now when he leaves
what would he be thinking now he yeah he
won't be offended so great you didn't
offend him you didn't scare him good for
you
but you also didn't impact him
you didn't move him
you didn't energize him
you didn't give them any kind of deeper
understanding of the faith
at all
now he went into church preparing to
encounter something deep holy
challenging
but he probably walked out thinking like
well what's all the fuss about
what's all the fuss about this Jesus
stuff that was just like that just
looked like something I could find
anywhere in the culture what was the
point of that
and this is the problem with
Christianity in this country not just in
our church buildings but everywhere it
has no edge it has no depth it has no
sense of its own ancient and epic
history there's no sacredness to it
there's no beauty there's no reverence
there's no pain there's no sacrifice all
of these things that are that are in
Christianity are not being brought out
and this is what people go to
Christianity for this is what they're
expecting this is what they want
when somebody walks especially a young
person who's never been to church and
they walk into a church building they
don't want to see a coffee shop they've
seen a million coffee shop they want
something totally different
you
but they don't find it
the light of faith grows dimmer in this
culture because Christianity has made
because I should say because the church
the American church has turned
Christianity into something lame and
boring
and that is a heck of an accomplishment
really when you think about it
I mean to make Christianity into
something lame and bored it's the least
lame the least boring thing in the
universe yet we have managed to turn it
into that
every branch of the faith has become
infected by this
and if we want to understand why why
Christianity is not winning souls and
especially not winning the younger
generation then we just got to look here
um
the strategy has been well if we want to
win back the sheep if we want to win
back the millennial sheep especially
then we have to make Christianity as
unchristian as possible it has to be
stripped of its truth of its sacredness
of its sacrifice of its of its morality
of its tradition of its history of its
hardships of its joy of its beauty of
everything and whatever's left I mean
it's not going to engage or excite
anyone but at least it won't scare them
away that's the idea
you
there's even you know you you find it in
some cases you have
these very old churches these very old
beautiful churches which do exist in
America we don't now we don't have
churches as old or as beautiful as what
they have in Europe but we still have
very old very beautiful churches and
sometimes what you'll find even is
that you know the church will go through
and they'll take away all the beautiful
that they'll make an effort they'll take
the effort to make the church less
beautiful
they'll take down the art they'll take
everything away and they'll try to make
it less beautiful they say to themselves
let's make Church less beautiful that's
it yeah because you know what that's
what's scaring people away is the beauty
I mean this this goes in everything that
this is even the way that the church the
new churches are constructed even the
architecture where they're made to look
bland like like office buildings or just
like nondescript auditoriums or from the
outside it looks almost like a DMV
office or something like that maybe
there's this even even the architecture
of churches has changed because they
want it's almost like they want to just
blend in with the landscape they want to
blend in with the culture as much as
possible they don't want anyone to know
that this is actually a church that
there's something different going on
here
the problem is
that the church is trying to appeal
to the wrong aspect of youth
you know they they see that young people
contend to be irreverent and frivolous
and easily distracted and in need of
constant stimulation and so they put
forward a Christianity tailored to those
qualities
but that's not the aspect of youth
Church should be trying to reach out to
okay young because young people are also
by nature radical idealistic hungry for
change hungry for a challenge
revolutionary most of the great
revolutionaries throughout history have
been young people that's no coincidence
revolutions are led by the young in
every case
you know revolutions are never led by 50
year olds so always by the young
so it should be no trouble at all to get
young people excited about Christianity
they want something radical they want
something revolutionary well
Christianity is exactly that they want
change Christianity can give them
exactly that they want higher ideals to
aspire to Christianity has exactly that
they want excitement Christianity is the
most exciting thing in the universe I
mean think about it as Christians we are
fighting a war against the devil himself
we are advancing against the darkest
forces of the universe and we're
marching with God on our side and all
the while all around us on a dimension
that's invisible to our mortal eyes
there are angels and demons and
supernatural forces both good and evil
and they're fighting and they're working
to defend and destroy us and this is all
happening all around the stakes are
infinite our souls hang in the balance
we're standing on a battlefield right
now as we speak
we are soldiers
the Psalms say praise be the Lord my
rock who trains my hands for war
that's what it says in Scripture
trains my hands for war
this is the feeling and the attitude
that our leaders and our churches should
be stirring in us this is the the truth
of this life and of the faith
it's a ferocious formidable terrifying
joyful beautiful fantastic amazing
wonderful truth it's the truth that the
scripture spends over a thousand pages
trying to explain and it's the truth
that should be shouted from the rooftops
of every single Church in America that's
how you stop the decline of Christianity
in America that's how you attract young
people by just simply telling them the
truth that's all
move them make them feel something make
them feel anger and fear and longing and
sadness and happiness and hope and
determination all of these things give
them something to aspire to
they want to change so give them a
reason to change give them a way to
change
you
that's how you attract the young people
this this should be you know
the conversation that we should be happy
having in America is you know how do we
keep the older people still invested in
Christianity how do we keep them
it should be no problem to get the young
people on board
this Christianity is something that
naturally appeals to them
because of its militant warring radical
nature
and as I said last week because in it
in the faith
and in Christ you find identity
and that is the thing most of all
that young people are looking for
identity purpose challenge sacrifice
we've got this idea that sacrifice is a
dirty word it nobody wants to do it no
that's that's not exactly right people
are looking for a reason to sacrifice
now it's not an easy thing to do
but that's the kind of message they want
and when a young person a secular young
person goes to a church
that's what they're looking to hear
looking to hear a challenging message of
sacrifice and battle and that's what
they want
it doesn't mean they're gonna
immediately you know convert
that's what they're interested in
hearing
that's the aspect of youth that's the
that is the thing in youthful nature
that we should be reaching out to and
appealing to and it should be pretty
easy to do
that's how you win back the young people
with the truth
and it is an incredible truth isn't it
all right
thanks for watching thanks for listening
everybody Godspeed